the Joe Rogan experience there that
whole derelict program you know was like
many things in my life started just from
a stupid passionate idea like I didn't
never never considered a business model
of doing it it was just okay I've got
two young kids I've got two labs I like
to do this I like to do that what do I
want as my next car and I'm like you
know what I'm tired of over restoring
[ __ ] cuz that's like my OCD I just
everything be perfect perfect and then
the first time you know the kids nail it
with a skateboard or I ding it with a
surfboard or the dog takes a piss and it
whatever like I don't want to be that
guy anymore so said you know what I
think I like want to find something
that's already [ __ ] up I'm just gonna
leave it looking all [ __ ] up son even
i washing cars and hate putting gas in
him so with the derelict all you do is
clean the windows and vacuum it at best
and party on and then I just put a
massive gas tank so my old 52 DeSoto
station wagon was the first derelict
that I built hundred percent myself
nights and weekends just because I had
this stupid idea in my head and I wanted
to realize it it wasn't until it was
done and it got like the cover a hot rod
and won all these awards that my dumb
ass went oh wait a minute
yeah we're honest and this still is you
know it fits within how we define the
icon brand holistically about revisiting
classic transportation design in a
modern context it's just a different way
of doing it so that was your first
derelict yeah
derelict til I was done and then we're
like okay let's brand them and we
started getting tons of requests we've
built some pretty wild array of them and
honey do your first one was for you yeah
yeah I mean it speaks to how weird it is
that you're doing that in the first
place because most people who are you
know high-dollar restoration and you
know air-quote resto mods or whatever
you want to call them everyone wants
them to be beautiful and pristine with
you know handles that that disappear you
know I mean everybody wants to shave
everything down and moving a lot of the
original character of the design that
they're supposed to be celebrating in
the first place so that compounded by
patina which tells a more personal story
of like where's this
I've been how to get that ding there's
like romance and mystery all wrapped
into one as far as the history behind
all those finishes how many big is a gas
tank in this thing that one's got like a
42 gallon gas tank I was like spare tire
gas tank spare dark like screw it three
cans of fix-a-flat and a big-ass gas
tank I hate stopping for gas well
especially with something like that it
must get like four miles to the gallon
that actually is a full emissions
equipped modern srt8 hemi 6.1 and it'll
get six you know what it's I don't
understand why but I don't have built
several Hemi based builds that is the
fastest and most fuel efficient of the
Hemi build I've ever done I mean that
thing gets probably 15 17 real yeah
we're not much metal and I Drive it like
an ass I mean I'm flogging that thing
granted I'm on my third transmission but
oh really yeah to the first you were
Mopar trainees which fellow builders
avoid them they suck if you add even
like five horsepower beyond the stock
motor app they completely shut
themselves so the third time I'm like
that's it I'm done pull the band-aid off
throw that thing away and put a good old
GM 4-leaf IV in there so this thing has
how many miles on it now I got about 38
39,000 miles on it so Wow
I love the split windshield - yeah it's
such a fun fun fun ride but you know
he's going all the way back to the
beginning of icon even further back to
the beginning of the first brand TLC
they all started with personal cars mmm
like the icon idea was just another dumb
idea that was rattling in my head it was
literally keeping me up at night and it
got to the point that I need and this
happens to me often like well you know
when I did my watch and then all the
different products that I've designed
generally you'll start with something
that gets to the point that I'll lose my
remaining sanity if I don't actually
create it so I had the concept for icon
I could see it clearly in my head I had
like a full-on 3d detailed model in my
head and like my version of jumping over
sheeps at night in bed was like sitting
there and zooming in on an element and
changing that radius and scaling this
and trying that and it literally got to
the point on my life I'm like I
I got to build it I just gotta build it
well your your company it's sort of it's
symbiotic with social media in a sense
particularly YouTube because so many
people on YouTube are interested in
unique builds and interesting companies
they're doing cool things like rev ology
mmm-hmm but your company in particular
it's so perfect because you do all those
videos and you drive around the cars
with this incredible detail and that's
one of the first things that got me very
attracted to your company was the fact
like I go look at this [ __ ] he's
so balls deep into this [ __ ] you're so
into it and if I'm not I won't take the
job so it's easy to say yeah you know
it's so contagious though when someone's
like really into something particularly
design and production and I totally like
if you're not totally into it and you're
not balls deep into it then pull out and
zip up and go home shut up yeah do
something else
is if you're not passionate about it you
you suck at it
[Applause]